Are you familiar with Accommodation, which is a probiotic?
Yes, a thread ran across it as a probiotic and that is said to help us side effects of recovery
of T-truda, if you don't therapy. I had three rounds of T-truda with people last
one in early November. My side effects were itchy, brashes skin,
dial, and dial Hashimoto's. I'm wondering if my bloated, distended belly could be from the
T-truda or an extension of T-truda and Hashimoto's. So when you have T-truda, so T-truda
is the neotherapy that blocks the PD1 receptor, which is the receptor that tells on T-cells
that tells them not to attack self-tition. Well, when you take a drug that blocks that,
now we start attacking self-titions. So the side effect of T-truda and other immunotherapy
drugs is that you could end up with an autoimmune disease. Now, once you have an autoimmune disease,
you have cell antibodies. That's what autoimmune disease is. Go back to that course and start learning
Can you take this probiotic and see if that helps with your gut? Sure, you can change and I
recommend that you change up to a probiotic set of regular on a basis.